[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for a brand
new tip 2019 interview super psyched to
be sitting with the team behind
sweetness in the belly first off huge
congratulations on the movie I do have
to trouble one of you to do this anybody
can jump in for anybody out there who
does not know what sweetness in the
belly is can you give a brief synopsis
of the movie light comedy
three cameras know its sweetness in the
belly is is that drama not light comedy
based on a book by kamila gab of the
same name and it's a story about a young
girl who was abandoned in Africa when
she was seven years old and and was
brought up by a Sufi Imam who became
that father figure to her and she goes
on to you know experience love and loss
in his time where Ethiopia was going
through a massive transformation in the
1970s and her life afterwards in in
England and trying to find that the
whole that you lost so second feature
film for you great success with the
first and I know everybody out there
it's always like all the pressure on the
sophomore effort so what was it about
this particular story that made you say
this is the right one to do next well to
be honest with you how timely it was
even though it was set in 1970s the
material itself speaks so loudly about
what is happening in the world today so
that was at the center of it and and
didn't hurt that also Ethiopia is also
part of in this part of the story and I
mean Theo pian and I live in Ethiopia
that was also it's there not a dullness
for me and I mean no brainer second
movie now you've shot in Ethiopia and
also for the two of you what is it about
making a movie in Ethiopia that you
could do there that you can't get the
same way somewhere else oh man I mean
yesterday I think he brought up to note
that so much of the infrastructure and
you know the architecture had not had
not changed
you know since since
between now and the time that the movie
is uh was a was set and and so just to
go in this step into the real
authenticity of the city you know we
weren't on built sets we were in the
homes and we were walking in the
community with the people so just to be
somewhere that we didn't have to
recreate but just to step down and to be
in a place that was authentic it really
made the made the story ring ring ring
true and it was that all that much more
important to to speak truth to that
location into the narrative and story
that we were telling anything you guys
want to add about shooting there I only
shot in Dublin oh yeah that's true as a
city that I think a lot of people know
so I don't know whatever my first time
it was my first time in Africa you know
and then so to have this project be the
project that takes me back to Africa
that's the first time I mean it was
really beautiful it was really emotional
and I felt a lot of responsibility but I
was also just blessed to be there and to
have my art it be something that brings
me to Africa into Ethiopia specifically
I mean I gotta tell you for me my wife
and was executive producer Verret
bringing an analyst crew and cast to
Ethiopia which we've never done before
and having our Ethiopian cast and crew
literally being mirroring these guys on
location was amazing I mean it was great
for the country was great for us for the
art community and and also that that
people saying that other people wanted
to hear from us you know other people
wanted to to know our history to know
our culture and I mean I was not a I
don't know a different world for me yeah
one of my favorite qualities about the
movie is that the main ensemble is
filled with characters who down to their
core are good people going out of their
way to do good things for others so if
you could each pick one quality of your
character to keep yourself what would it
be for me is
you know I'm required love for someone
who's wounded I think oftentimes we we
judge people who are wounded because I
don't know they robbed us the wrong way
or whatever but I realized that if you
can truly be compassionate it brings you
closer to yourself
I would say Aziz is courage you know he
he had a choice to to stay and fight or
to or to leave and have a better life
and he chose to he chose to stay and to
fight likely knowing that that he would
not be the person to talk to cause the
change but I think he was willing to be
to be a spark you know toward the fire
that was necessary yeah I don't know if
he met a few met this guy who came to us
at the after party
Ethiopian guy was actually came on to us
and he seen the film and said you you
guys were spot-on he said I was in her
at that time he was in prison
Wow so he's like Aziz could have been a
character written after my story Wow
talk to Camille ugh it was just I
literally was like oh my god you know
that was one of the things that we were
we wanted to connect to the in they're
still around there's people that that
happened to their survivors are still
around and it's very fresh in their eyes
another thing that really struck me
about the movie is just the idea of
making a home and it doesn't have to be
in the traditional sense you can find it
anywhere so for all three of you what is
one thing that has to be constant no
matter where you go when it comes to
calling a place home I mean it for me
it's community the people you surround
yourself with you could be anywhere in
the world but if you were people you
love that's home for me I mean right now
I'm living a very nomadic lifestyle you
know I don't I don't have an apartment
you know couple pieces of luggage right
do you know for me I get into a place
you know for for a job and I open up my
suitcase I put up a picture of my mom
and a picture of my dad you know and
that makes home for me so it's really
about it's about family it's about
community and being able to connect to
someone or talk
to an idea that makes me feel feel safe
and loved you know you know we come from
an ancient culture right and that is in
so many ways for me like going back to
Ethiopia after living in the US for 22
years and seeing those elements that I
was brought up in I kind of go like oh
wow so I was able to create that away
from home and the friends that I made at
school at work and playing soccer
that became home so to me that was that
I think that was the same for ever
before everybody so that was for me I
don't think there's a better way to and
those are beautiful answers thank you
guys so much for sharing you thank you
today a huge thanks to everybody out
there watching this please keep an eye
out for sweetness in the belly and a
special thanks to our sponsors at
Nordstrom Canada for making these
interviews happen hey that's it for this
one we're gonna have more until 2019
coming your way real soon